foreign
[Music]
champions of this realm can do nothing
to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that
[Music]
a lot has changed in the last few years
a wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers
all right here's the situation
[Music]
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us
he ripped it from our father's call okay
I feel like maybe I should be writing
all this down give us the powers child
your world will not survive this
you want these Powers come get them hey
Khaleesi
we have one job to do exceed the world
finally
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I can't do this take my powers back you
came to me so you would take them back
right
I speak Millennia
searching for a worthy champion
exactly what must be done
Billy what are you doing I have to do
this we end this now
we do
start in front of him nowhere
foreign
[Music]